[Music]
hello welcome to SH October 2018 when we
await the coming of Halloween the time
of the year when all the dark beings of
the world come out of hiding and flood
our streets it's a long-standing
tradition when we consciously come into
contact with the darker aspects of the
world monsters death and perhaps above
all evil why are we so fascinated by
death it's been part of our culture as
for as long as there have been recorded
history but where does all this come
from is it perhaps our basis in our
religious traditions and what are the
stories trying to convey these are the
kind of questions we will be exploring
in these videos so get ready turn down
the lights and I will take you through
the story of evil MA
[Music]
in ancient Egypt death was a big deal
some of the most famous monuments and
buildings from this period like the
pyramids were built with the explicit
reason of of cheating impermanence and
the transitory nature of the world in
other words of cheating death
nonetheless death was a reality for the
Egyptian and it permeates their art and
mythology to these people death wasn't
the end and they faced this difficult
question by preparing meticulously for
this event and also by telling stories
about what happens after according to
Egyptian thought once you leave this
world you enter the afterlife and
depending on if you've been a good
person in this mortal life you might end
up in a paradise like land called the
field of reeds but to get to this
blissful place you had to face quite a
few challenges on the way the afterlife
was thought to be kind of like a mirror
to this world which is why a lot of
people were buried with their belongings
and and and their sort of grave palaces
often mirrored their palaces in this
world because they just thought that
that could help them on the other side
the soul or car of a person had to be
taken care of the bodies were often
mummified in a very long and complicated
process in which every detail mattered
the mummification process was done to
preserve the body for all eternity so
that the soul could recognize it and
return to it all the inner soft organs
were removed the brain the heart and so
on
they were often placed in jars next to
the coffin all moisture was removed from
the body it was packed with dry salt and
then wrapped in linen which created that
classic mummy look we all loved from the
movies
[Music]
after death the person had to go through
a number of chambers of a kind of Hell
where they had to battle monsters and
demons they had to cross lakes of fire
this place in other words was not very
pleasant at all and not everyone made it
to the other side this is for example
why we often see boats in the burial
chambers of Kings because it is thought
that they needed these boats to cross
these lakes of fire and get to to the
eventual paradise land but even if you
got to the end of this terrible journey
you still weren't done in later Egyptian
mythology once there you were met by the
god Osiris god of the afterlife as well
as Anubis and a terrible monster or
beast called the unmet this was a beast
made up of three different animals it
had the head of a crocodile the upper
body of a lion and the lower body of a
hippopotamus it is especially
interesting to consider that these three
were of course the three animals that
Egyptians fear the most the most deadly
animals that existed in this region at
the time and this is a perfect example
of of mythology and religion mirroring
the society in which it is conceived in
this case were the three most deadly
animals is is combined into this
terrible monster that is often known as
the soul eater or devourer of souls once
in this room Anubis would take the heart
of the deceased which was considered the
seed of the soul and he would place it
on a scale next to the feather of Ma'at
Martin Ainge indeed it was this concept
of justice and order in the universe
also sometimes considered as a God and
now if you had been a good person
throughout your life your heart would be
light and if it was lighter or as light
as the feather of Ma'at
then you would be allowed to enter the
field of reeds and live in paradise
forever however if you've been a bad
person your heart was heavy and if
unfortunately your heart is heavier than
the feather of Maude
your heart was fed to the Soul Eater and
the person was doomed to spend eternity
in Oblivion the Amud monster here is a
perfect representation of what people
fear the most a theme that is recurring
in the history of mythology religion and
storytelling throughout the world you
could say it is the point of telling
such stories abstract ideas and fears
are given a mythological embodiment and
told in a language that made sense to
the people who were exposed to it in
this case the most terrible fate a
person could experience is embodied by
three animals people fear the most see
the connection here
[Music]
in ancient Greece evil has a very clear
mythological beginning you see there was
this woman created by the gods called
Pandora who was created by Zeus in order
to enact a revenge on the human race as
well as the god Prometheus who had
betrayed him Zeus created Pandora and
made her to be the most beautiful woman
imaginable before sending her down to
the world of men but she was also given
a box although some say was actually a
jar and yes it is that Pandora's box and
now under no circumstances were she to
open this box and for a while she
actually didn't but as time went on her
curiosity got the better of her and she
she just had to see what was inside so
she very carefully opened the lid but it
was already too late all the evil death
and sickness and terrible things in this
world had escaped and infected the
worlds of men in that very moment death
was created sickness greed Envy hatred
and all the darkness of the world
thankfully the world wasn't completely
ruined because there was one last little
thing left in this box which Pandora
also ultimately released and that was
hope moreover in ancient Greece there
existed the concept of the underworld
which also sometimes took the name of
its ruler Hades it was here that the
souls of the dead would be transported
it's kind of similar to the Egyptian
idea of the afterlife
except there's no weighing of the heart
no judgment as such and no real paradise
come to think of it maybe it isn't that
similar to Egyptian mythology at all
anyway the point is that there is an
afterlife and in ancient Greece this
afterlife was kind of meaningless it was
spent in Hades and and you were just
kind of there this stands in stark
contrast to other religions that are to
a larger degree at least still alive
today and that is the indian traditions
of hinduism and buddhism
like later amount of theistic religions
as well as to some degree
the Egyptian mythology there exists in
Buddhism and Hinduism this idea of being
rewarded or punished for for your
actions in this life only
it takes a slightly different form
rather than being judged as such and
sent to a heaven or hell in the indian
religions they believe in reincarnation
that is after death your soul is reborn
in a new body depending on how you act
in this life you may end up getting a
worse or better life the next time
around so for example if you're a good
person you will get a better life next
time and if you're a bad person you'll
get a worse one so you may end up being
an animal like a dog because that seems
so awful right you're going on
nonetheless all of this is determined by
a very famous concept called Karma that
you gather throughout your life and the
whole goal of this long journey is to
eventually and hopefully be released
from this eternal death and rebirth
cycle and achieve liberation known as
moksha now if we turn to Persia and the
religion of Zoroastrianism which
historically is one of the most
significant and important religions of
all time we're going to run into a
perspective on evil that may appear very
similar to some of us in the West there
is some scholarly debate on whether so
astron ism should be considered a
monotheistic or a dualistic faith that
is if they believe and worship one
Almighty God or two deities but
nonetheless whichever position you hold
the main aspects of its theology still
remain two sir Austrians the world is
made up of two opposing forces that of
lights and good and that of evil and
darkness the world was created by the
god Ahura Mazda and all good and
benevolent creator this also means that
in its original state the world
was perfect there was no evil no
darkness no death nothing of this sort
however there was another being called
Angra Mainyu which could be seen as the
embodiment of darkness and he managed to
corrupt the world and infuse it with
everything that is dark evil and
negative the disagreements among
historians scholars and so Astra's
themselves regard whether Knut Angra
Mainyu should be considered a God in
himself that stands in opposition or
beside Ahura Mazda or if he's simply
part of our masters creation as such but
nonetheless the deed was done and this
was the start of the long battle between
light and darkness that would rage
throughout creation you see - Soros
ruins the world as we know it is a
constant battle between good and evil
between light and darkness our very
purpose in this world is to fight the
darkness little by little constantly
pushing it back and promoting the good
things in the world so that eventually
evil will be forever annihilated and the
world returns to its original perfection
what is especially significant here is
the emphasis on the essence of evil
which is embodied in Angra Mainyu a
deity or a spirit an evil being that
stands in opposition and as a nemesis
to the benevolent creator god sound
familiar
you've probably guessed at this point
that the idea of Angra Mainyu in surah
astron ism is very likely the source of
the Christian and and monotheistic idea
of the devil not only that but in surah
astron ISM there are lesser spirits that
serve Ahura Mazda and lesser spirits
that serve angra mainyu which likely
corresponds to the later concepts of
angels and demons there are many
interesting aspects of Surrealism and
its influence on the later Abrahamic
religions but we'll talk about that at
another time what is particularly
interesting now is this concept of
evil that appears in this tradition we
see the different ancient religious
traditions tackle subjects such as death
sickness and violence in different ways
from the Egyptian concepts of the
afterlife and the soul devourer to
Pandora's box and also the Indian
traditions finally in surah Astron ISM
evil is given a very concrete identity
as a constant force in the world that is
an opposition to the forces of good
embodied in the being of Angra Mainyu
and his servants a dualistic outlook
that would have enormous impact on the
history of ideas and the history of evil
itself in the next episode we will be
looking at the judeo-christian Islamic
framework and how the idea of the devil
and his demons has evolved and changed
I'll see you then